we are joined here with
home base featuring two very special
guests brother gabriel al romani
and mahdi tajani salam alaykum
what time is it respectively where you
guys are at
uh
father father it's 11 p.m for me bro
it is 6 a.m for me there we go there we
go at 6 p.m for house 3.
all right so i want to give a quick
shout out first and foremost to
all our beautiful brothers and sisters
who tuned in
jessica lochere for making the time
being in the comments going crazy
however please try to keep it respectful
please try not to spam you know any bots
guys we're going to get the moderators
to handle that
all right with that being said
what's on your mind bro
um not much to be honest i think which
is just inshallah get right into it
um i guess you know i'll kind of
moderate a little bit for the sake of uh
transparency and order so bismillah so
wealth and subscribe and all that
alhamdulillah really good advice there
it wasn't really big you know an issue
at all i enjoyed the absolute
alhamdulillah
second episode came around and we had
this uh
very big discussion talking about single
motherhood that was the aim of it
and all of that and there's a lot of
points made right so for example one of
the points made
was uh divorcees and what islam
says or what we can derive from islamic
um scripture
or islamic texts about divorcees and
what the prophet
said did this that the other this
another
so brother gabriel in the discussion we
just had recently
you had a bit of a a refutation or a
clarification
on the usual that was used and how it
doesn't exactly
add up in the uh you know the proper
shuttle reform
so do you want to begin
well i think uh
it's better if mahdi starts to maybe
explain to us a bit better inshallah
what he means
so we give him the benefit of the doubt
man you know last time we had the
discussion without him
it's only fair that we bring him on so
bismillah
well for those of you who are
who are in this platform right now you
watched both the podcasts
so it's difficult for me to know where
to start without understanding
precisely what point it is you would
like me to clarify
so if we start from that angle what
point specifically would you like me to
go over
and then we can take it from there
let me start then alhamdulillah
allah
oh for people to spectate and to i don't
even know what's going on on youtube
the objective behind this discussion is
to
basically clarify a few things that
have been said i've checked some of the
shows that you've made some of the posts
brother mehdi
i don't really know you this is the
first time we actually talk
kind of face to face on this platform
we haven't actually communicated before
so as i said in my previous
podcast with the brothers as well you
know we have to be
fair to you we have to be honest
this is a brother in islam
every now and then i think it's the
internet not only
yeah it's not the mic it's probably the
internet
i'll try to so i think maybe just some
misunderstanding so i looked at some of
your
some of your videos and looked at some
[Music]
that you've said in the past oh you've
said they've made many mistakes in the
past and i'm not here to
to judge you i'm just here to
correct a few misconceptions okay and i
think we're going to keep it to a few
points number one is the issue of
red pill whether it's compatible with
islam
and the issue that you hold or the
position that you hold on marrying
divorced women so
these are basically the things that i
want to
clarify and number one
um i don't believe whatsoever the red
that islam is compatible with red pill
you kind of make the point about red
print being above
your internet that's how you're about to
make a point
if you could repeat that
okay i'm not sure why this is lagging
let me maybe close some of these
fights bro yeah and always
um gabriel if you wouldn't have if you
wouldn't mind
closing all your tabs that you're not
using because a lot of the time
streaming out uses a lot of bandwidth
i'm i mean they're they're closed
there's nothing heavy on my side
it's good now you can continue
[Music]
that's all pen let's see here
should work okay so what i said is that
red pill is not compatible to islam
saying red pill is compatible with islam
just because it the concept of red pill
which comes from the matrix right you
take either the red pill or the
blue pill it's kind of like saying that
you know well
uh the monotheism or tahita of the
christians is
is tauhid uh yeah they're talking about
tahitian oneness of god but when you
actually go
to their theology and you look at the
details then you'll find that it's
totally incompatible with what islam
says so in concept in principle
you can say follow the red pill wake up
cool all right concept wise but when you
actually go down to the details
and you look for example who proposes
these theories that come from red pill
you know such as tomasi and others who
cannot put two sentences together
without saying the f word
you can see the type of discussions they
usually hold
and others be it the guy who's
entrepreneurs in cars
be it uh fresh and fit guys right may
allah guide the
sudanese brother so you know what i mean
it's like
when you actually look at the details
you'll find
that it's not compatible with sound i'm
in field of psychology
you can say well the study of the psyche
of the mind
and the soul the relationship but what
yeah i can say man islam is all about
that right imam ghazali has the model of
the human soul
and the mind you know mudin you can say
it's compatible when you go to analyze
the theories in psychology you'll find
that
are they're coming from an atheistic
perspective god is not there
god is a concept for human beings to
help them to
you know understand what's not
understandable in the world
so i'm a major in psychology i've come
from that background
do i believe psychology is compatible
with this
um i mean when you get to the
nitty-gritty of things
then you'll find that yes there are some
things there that are just
observable truths or things that you can
test but is it really compatible with
islam in all principles
you'll find that no so i'll make the
argument
that you know when someone says
something is compatible with islam
you basically have to to prove that you
know what i mean
and when you i would say that if anyone
reads their stuff boy
men and women whatever it is they'll
find certain things that they can
resonate with
but in general you'll find that it's not
com
parabol
it what they talk about be it who
proposes this like which
scholar or islam of islam pastor
president would
uphold such things if you're talking
about just the concept of truth
all right hey let's all swallow the
truth
whatever you want to call it red pill
and so on that's what islam is about
what will
happen
indeed truth has come and it knocks
falsehood out indeed falsehood
is bound to be knocked so that's
something that i would say i'll leave it
for the first point and the second point
about divorcees
maybe
we'll do we'll do one point at a time
should we address your first point all
right
all right before you go abroad i would
advise that we try to keep the whole
thing
as a goal one and a half hours in um
take about five
ish minutes for this main point if
that's enough time for you uh mahdi
and do start with a brief introduction
what is the red pill because a lot of
people don't
don't have any clue of what we're
talking about sure so
before i get to to that you know
explaining
what the red pill is um i have another
question for brother gabriel and that is
outside of the matrix uh illustration
you gave
because there's a lot of different um
people who lay claim to that
you know we woke even those on the far
left
claim to be red pill because they're
woke masha'allah
right so from a perspective of this
discussion
of intersexual relationship dynamics
what is your understanding of the red
pill
i there's i don't think this point is
relevant bro i'm trying to tell you
you've said red pill is compatible with
islam we want you to clarify that
i'm not here to be questioned about what
my understanding of the red pill is
you're basically dodging the point
the point is is red pill in its
form whatever you want to call it is it
compatible
with islam red pill is known we know who
their proponents are
whoever claims right to it or names to
it you know where the red pill blue pill
comes from
all right it's about being awakened okay
so we want you to explain to us whether
red pill is compatible with islam
what are the evidences for that simple
is that it's not my understanding of the
red pill we could go in a discussion for
two hours
you need to explain to us this is
important this is an important point to
establish because until we establish a
foundation we can't build a house
so for me to know how to best address
this with you specifically
i will repeat my question it's not a
point my question is
what is your understanding of the red
pill from a perspective of intersexual
relationship dynamics
my brother we've been discussing or what
i've had an issue with
and a lot of the community is how your
understanding of the red pill
led you to believe that you shouldn't be
in general marrying divorced women
right based on what i've looked at from
your lectures
and what you've put out there so my
point is
i'm not here to be questioned about
what's my understanding of the red pill
with regards to
intersexual relationships it's not a
about i mean you can say okay until we
have a foundation
we don't have discussion that's what i'm
trying to get to you for you to explain
to us
okay as we said we have a discussion
there's been some accusations made of
you and we just want to understand
where how can you explain to us
statements that you've made such as that
these things are compatible
uh we are all wrong in understanding a
red pill you've made a video
reaction to my video as to why so many
men muslim men follow red pill
okay i was speaking in general about
what red pill is for example
uh you know royal tomasi and his
rational man
book right i was reading through it
someone sent it
as um as a gift okay this guy is someone
who
pushes the understanding of red pill
what i told you is that
in concept about if it's about truth or
waking up
hey we can say yes cool no problem
but when it is about a movement and
specifically let's be specific then
how it looks at divorced women
okay pair bonding um what you've been
saying about and advising people
not to marry divorced women you know how
that is linked to your understanding of
what sunnah and what's not based on the
af
of the prophet saw asylum if you want me
to get specific then
this is what we need to discuss now
what's my understanding of
of what you know a red pill and how it
relates to
i think i mean there's no point to
discuss i mean there's no discussion
okay so listen mahdi can you know
correct me if by by all means if i'm
wrong bro
uh inshallah but my point my my point is
everything is halal until it's proven
haram
so matthew is coming from a point of
view where it's like you have
your contention your point your
viewpoint that red pill is not
compatible with islam
and maggie has a point that it is so
from us from that strict perspective
he's asking for any points that you know
you could bring up as in what is your
understanding of red pill
so he can understand why you think it's
haram or why it's not compatible with
the sun
okay all right fine let's get a bit more
specific it seems that now i have to
explain myself
as opposed to brother mahdi is having to
explain himself okay number one red pill
cannot be compatible islam because it's
coming from a position of kofo
all right it is mostly coming from a
position
of if you look at their writings of
non-muslims who
usually based it on their experience
especially like tomasi is a
he's a behaviorist he calls himself at
the beginning of the book of behaviors
and others is what they have experienced
from their
skewed experience of life
yes they do cite you know some uh
they do cite some statistics and so on
but in general has nothing to do with
islam
islam is very clear it has foundations
it has legal maxims
it has specific things that are based on
wahi what is revelation from allah the
almighty
which cannot be at fault well the red
pill it has
what's called kalam or philosophy of
human beings
have been debating and discussing these
issues for a long time
okay philosophers have been detrimental
to islam
for a long time have they brought some
benefit
no doubt about it that's what we're
saying is there some truth and certain
things that are
decent or could be understood within red
pill i've said that many times
all right is it compatible with islam
is it something for young men to go into
and you can see the outcomes of that
of course not because in the words of
brother mahdi
the foundation is quick send you cannot
build
foundation on kuffar it's like
islamicizing education i'm a
school principal i always deal with
curriculum people say you can take the
cambridge pathway you can say it then
take the common core standards
and islamicize him i always make the
argument you're islamising something
that is not islamic
you're building your foundation or your
house
in the words of mahdi on quicksand quran
in sunnah
is not a philosophy quran sunnah is
divinely
revealed from allah subhanahu wa we base
our muammar
what brother fayat to correct you said
everything is halal
until this proven otherwise
in the dealings of human beings okay but
here when you study their books or you
read through their books just take the
rationale men okay by allah
if anyone reads that book can you say
that this is compatible with islam
okay the way brother mahdi talks about
divorced women
is it coming from quran in sunnah or is
it coming from red
pill because if that would be the only
evidence to base to justify basically if
brother mehdi is a proponent of the red
pill
for example the way the languages that
he uses
calling guys you know cook and swearing
and using bad words
well again i would say
whoever believes in allah they let him
say something good or keep quiet
you know what i mean if you're telling
me that that's what we can observe
from your behavior what you propose how
you talk about
uh divorced women body counts as if
there be murderers body counts are
usually used
for you know for people who killed
someone
how many body counts did you have in
murder and killing
right if these this is the kind of
language that comes out of red pill
then i don't think there is a discussion
whether that is compatible
with islam or not now this is
something quite simple
versus you know
entrepreneurs in cars or fresh and fit
or
whatever scientist or statistics or
research
you want to use if that's your ultimate
truth
and that is truth then hey you know what
i mean that's
your uh point they're coming from but
we basically when we look at something
in this life
worshiping allah be it dealings with
people
the quran and sunnah come
first and that is why forget about sims
and women and this and that it's very
easy to
to dismiss people by saying oh they're
just you know
sims it's just the youth they're just
this and that it's not about that man
it's about you can see the outcomes when
people
you know you try to explain to people
from an understanding of the quran
sunnah if a person is muslim he has got
no argument he's got to submit
you know what i mean but if you're
coming from that perspective of red pill
you can see the outcomes and
the problems that you can get yourself
in all right there's there's one thing i
want to make clear because
i i don't know if it was clear because
when i heard brother gabriel say it it
didn't exactly click in my head but i do
understand like the point because i
thought of it as well so
this this concept of halal until proven
haram applies for sharia
applies for the sharia the islamic you
know law
whether it's upon the community the
individual so on and so forth right
it does not in any way shape or form
apply to al-qaeda belief
if i were to claim something about allah
anything i need evidence
i need evidence right i can't say it's
halal for me to believe this until you
prove it wrong
that's an argument from ignorance when
it comes to al-qaeda when it comes to
sharia is it halal for me to you know
touch this microphone and move it up and
down
no one can say it's haram and i don't
need to prove it's halal just wanted
to make that clear
having heard you speak brother gabriel
it sounds to me that
the fear here is that this red pill and
i don't even like this name red pill by
the way it sounds cringy now
but it sounds to me like the fear with
red pill is that it's an ideology
but i'd be correct in saying that
it is an ideology okay okay
um what makes you say that
well because it has its proponents it
has this book it's become a dean it is a
dean
okay like any other right uh
ideology in the world be it communism be
it
capitalism be it whatever the prophet
says
is a path of life it's a way that's been
adopted atheism is an ideology it's a
religion actually if you want to
actually go down to
uh satanism is a religion or an ideology
it's got books it's got people arguing
for it
people calling to it it fits those
okay red pill is not an ideology it's a
praxology
are you familiar with the difference
between the two terms
okay enlighten us i mean it's very easy
to come up with
with terms or to discussions but i think
we're missing the point of the
discussion brother mahdi
we're guessing what i mean we're going
there
some things take time so an ideology as
you mentioned
it's uh it's an ism there is a religion
or is an ism such as socialism marxism
communism is a
a group of individuals who come together
and formulate
some ideas he pulled it from his pocket
and he decided
today i invent socialism today i invent
marxism atheism on and on right
red pill is not an ideology it's a
praxology
and the definition of a praxology is
one sentence the study of human conduct
and behavior
okay what's your evidence for that for
your claim right now
again the question needs to be
formulated differently
if you you claim that it is an ideology
the burden of proof is upon the claimant
no my brother because that red pill
exists uh
a hundred years ago this name this
ideology
again as i mentioned at the beginning of
the stream that the term red pill has
been hijacked by anyone who claims to be
woke right and even my brother even
brother
sorry one moment even the far leaning
left have hijacked this term
but if we remove the frame okay let's
let's
let's throw this frame away red pill
take away the frame
what are we left with we are left with
the proxology
the study of human conduct and behavior
i just want to interject okay uh this is
yeah
so um with the with the proxology in
ukraine it's just the study of human
nature right so praxology the study of
human nature
there's no problem with studying human
nature right but when an individual
comes to certain conclusions
based off of that in which they're now
viewing life in a way that's a practice
ology
or they're teaching it or promoting it
it becomes an ideology because the
definition of an ideology
is basically um a system of ideas or
ideals
now they're mainly political right
especially political ones but that it's
not
limited to to political endeavors it
could just be
um a series of ideas now there is no one
solid book
on um on red pill there is not
but it has morphed the same way feminism
has morphed over the years
dreadful has morphed over the years and
perhaps it has been hijacked
but the truth of the matter is in a
communal sense when you use the term red
pill
people don't look it as a as a praxology
and it's it's a way it's it's more
beyond that because now people are
taking it and they're my brothers
rulings my brothers my brothers we are
here
to discuss okay
brother mahdi's understanding of how red
pill is compatible
with quran and sunnah specifically what
he claims about divorced women very
simple two points
if you want to have another discussion
about the definition of red pill and the
philosophy whether it's a proxology or
an ideology
let's make another debate that i'm not
really necessarily interested in because
these are like debate tactics you know
we're missing the point
we are missing the point the important
connection here is not just about the
definition of red pill
what it has led mahdi to believe and
what he advocates on tick tock and on
youtube and on instagram or wherever he
is what platforms
[Music]
five minutes in debating the issue of
ideology proxology
it's like okay proxology says who
because you say it's the study of human
nature
well psychology is a study of human
nature the psyche
islam or the fitra you could say is the
study of human knowledge
and you'll be like prove it well because
i claim so because it says in a book
i've asked you was it defined as this
100 years ago
was it the term even used a hundred you
know so someone took it out of the
pocket
someone condor came with this term red
pill it did not exist before
meaning as per your definition be it
marxism or
sociology or whatever you want you you
used before
someone with this term
so you could it's your opinion that it's
a proxology and the study of human
nature and so on
but it's not all right we need to
discuss here
what people see from red pill what red
pill is pushed again
today not about being awakened or being
you know in line with what is truth i
told you already just that concept
itself
it's fine and dandy bro that is in line
with you know allah calls us to
the truth anyway we don't need
rolotomasi or any other philosopher
psychologist or scientist for that
matter
to do and when you look throughout your
stuff that you put out there
that's exactly the what you think
call it this study call it this other
psychologist or
social scientist and we're saying
it's very simple okay which one is going
to take precedence brother mandy
so i think let's get to the point that
is linked to your understanding of red
pill which is about divorced women and
you
encouraging men not to even get
married to divorce women it's not a
sunnah
not just that you're talking about body
counts you are
disrespecting women who are divorced
putting them in all pretty much in the
same plate
talking and making a lot of claims about
you know divorced women
which again are not in line with the
quran
actually it is it is a lie
you know behave that you are missing
here my brother
okay show us it's brother gabriel still
there
you're there yeah
so again to reiterate the point before
we move forward because it's impossible
to build out a proper discussion
without establishing the foundations red
pill
keep going sorry red pill at its core
is a proxology of study now is it
possible for people to run with
that and turn it into a ism yes
definitely it's definitely possible but
at its core
it is not an ideology okay it's no more
of an ideology than
fayyad who's in the fitness industry and
decides one day he's going to
establish his own type of training
routine
which gets you into shape and he calls
it fayad fit
and many people flock to him to learn
from him because he's successful and
good at what he does
and he brings people results now
suddenly
this this gathering becomes a little
cultish
and they make a almost like an idol
outfit a fire
now it's become an ideology but at its
core fayad was simply teaching the
people
how to get into shape and he was
successful at doing so
that's a praxology
okay great so let's get them to the
point
uh because that's not what you talk
about in your videos that's not what you
are necessarily clarifying maybe you
have done in some of your videos
but not that's not the main core which
is again evidence
for your you've taken even i would make
the accusation you've taken red pill
and this label and run away with it have
amalgamated it with islam have quoted a
few hadith here and there
and you have tried to make certain
points that are
restricted to your personal experience
in your marriages maybe
which you already talked abouted to
these issues your experiences
with women in polygyny and so on and so
forth so you say
in some of the videos this is why you
wake up every morning and you do it for
free
because you've gone you've seen how it
is so you are fighting and trying to
reduce divorce
quote you say i'm not going to eliminate
divorce but at least i will try to
reduce it so it seems like okay fine in
your words you've taken this concept and
you've run with it
and you've made up your own type of
ideology
uh because the discussion again is not
whether it's ideology or proxology
uh going back i don't know how many
years and who's taking
it and who's it's about you being
claiming online
about divorced women all right so you're
dodging again what i'm trying to
uh raise here why we are here to discuss
this issue and don't you know i mean
it's known to people what you've been
claiming online yes your tick tock
account's been
taken down i think a few times but
people have saved some of your videos
i've actually taken some time
to look at your videos i've actually
taken some time to analyze some of the
things
this is what i would say is important so
yes you take
you took the red pill you start saying
that it's compatible with islam
so you need to tell us how because we
don't understand
me
especially the way you present it okay
with using swear words
using bad words alluding to different
studies and so on and basically
specifically to this point of
how men muslim men should not marry
divorced women
it's high body count okay like murder
we shouldn't forgive them allah forgives
them for their past but we shouldn't
so explain to us how is that compatible
with quran
sunnah what are you trying to preach to
people forget about whether the people
get upset or not bro
sims or feminists or this and that
to agree with one thing that i believe
is very important
uh is brother fayad what he said
feminism is bleeding into the ummah i
totally agree 100
110 i agree
and i understand brother mahdi may allah
protect
you and guide you that you are trying to
do some work
you have had some experiences in your
life
not because i'm saying this is because
you've said that in your
videos and your tick tocks and that is
my argument that your experiences are
skewed
and so is your vision of what married
women are of your
advice to young men who will take these
advices
look at you and say okay
i'm not going to do this mistake that
brother mehdi has done as well so you're
what you're saying online bro as the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam said
everyone is responsible for who's below
them you are taken as some kind of a
public figure even though you said i'm
not a student of knowledge
i'm not this i'm not that we're going to
get to some of the sharia terms that
you've been used and how you've
understood them
from perspective but basically you're
responsible bro for what you are saying
i'm trying to tell you here and to
advise you
as your brother and i can see already
that is very excited to uh to maybe even
jump in
but we have to be honest here bro
we have to be as honest as possible
we are analyzing some of the things that
you've claimed
and some of the compatibilities you've
claimed between
whether it's red pill in its core or as
you have taken it and made it and
islamicized it as you can see from your
videos
or whatever it's the burden of proves
upon you to show us that
what you are preaching is compatible
with islam let's go more specific then
as and more specific to with regards to
divorced
women okay so first thing and for mostly
let's talk about my personal experiences
and that general
question or that general angle
when people ask me oh it's because of
your bad experiences
or have you been hurt or who hurt you
my response to them is the following
that's not a good
question and the reason why is as
follows
that question drags us into the feelings
world
and it doesn't require
require us to intellectually challenge
the argument itself
why because if i say yes
i've been hurt then immediately the
people can go away and say
ah that's why he thinks like that and
there's no need to it to exert
any intellectual calories because now we
have a reason
and if i say no the people will say he's
lying
he has been hurt so i say to you let's
put that question to the side
let's put that point to the side whether
i have been hurt
or haven't been hurt it's irrelevant
because it drags the level of the
discussion down
and then my question back to you is
specifically
what point do you take issue with and
let's address that
at an intellectual level and actually
brother gabriel let's let's go one point
to another point so let's stick to one
one single point at a time
i i've been sticking bro to two points
this whole time number one
is the issue of misunderstanding let me
be more specific
of red pill how he's islamicized it and
how would that lead leads
into or bleed through the concept of
what he is proposing online about and
and encouraging young men not to marry
or any man not to marry
divorced women which is causing a huge
problem all right i don't want to get
into
now uh details because you're going to
say i'm adding a point
but just to respond to magni i agree
with you bro we shouldn't be talking
about our personal experiences and i
don't think i used the word hurt
uh i don't know where did you put that
in i didn't use that whether you were
hurt or not that's up to you man i'm not
in your
shoes however back at you bro why do you
use than your personal experiences you
yourself in your videos
not
this is as that is you know kind of like
an argument from experience
but you also talk about certain issues
of your past
and certain you know uh legal issues
that you've had
which has no point i would argue the
same thing let's get to the intellectual
discussion that's where
my point is the intellectual discussion
the correct discussion would be
based on quran and sunnah based on
objective measures
of issues that you have claimed not on
your personal experiences whether you've
been divorced and how many many women
you married and why it failed
and what you advise men not to you know
do polygamy
and why you advise them not to do
peregrini and you know whether you've
sorry physically reprimanded your wife
of your child what's the point of you
putting those things i mean i would
advise you as your brother
okay
this deen is advised so i advise you
brother to keep your matters your
personal matters to yourself
i would say then a lot of people would
maybe listen to you
more for example if you were cut the
swearing and you would keep your
personal matter so take this advice that
you just given me three minutes ago
and apply it to yourself my brother and
then go ahead and see i think people
react a little bit different to you
as opposed to when you talk about your
personal experiences or how you
reprimanded your son
or your daughter physically and how you
are charged
for that and you know then because yeah
then
you're right people are actually going
to intellectually switch off
and they're going to go emotionally so
you're telling us you're preaching us to
us that hey let's
not go emotionally let's turn on
intellectually i'm telling the same
thing apply this rule to yourself
i think you would reduce some of the
negative impact that you are causing
online
simple so the only time i draw upon
personal experiences
is if i have first come forward with
either a study
or some type of statistic that i quote
first and if i happen to have had
personal experience
with relation with with regards to that
statistic then i will quote him
otherwise i don't
so i mean that doesn't uh refute the
point that i just made bro
it's just emphasizes it but carry on man
i i stick to the advice that i give you
my brother from the bottom of my heart
okay
just keep your private matters to
yourself speak academically
quote the studies whatever you want to i
think people might
listen to you a bit better when you
bring in your personal experiences
what you've done to your wife and your
son i believe that's not something
that's going to be in your favor
so brother gabriel's point about you
islamicizing red pill
uh what would you say to that it's not
an islamic matter it's not a religious
matter
any more than failed fitness enterprises
so why do you quote hadith or trying to
bring the two together you've been using
and mixing it with what you are trying
to prove so how is it not a religious
matter
okay so you correctly stated that i make
it very clear to the people
i do not position myself as an islamic
authority
and if i make a mistake with regards to
the deen i expect to be checked which is
why we're having this conversation right
now
i am not there i am not i am not an
islamic authority
okay this is very important now what was
your question again remind me sorry
i forgot your question
i adore myself yourself brother gabriel
your question has left my mind oh why do
i
bring anything yeah you said this is not
an islamic matter right yes
so the only time i will bring in an ayah
a hadith of the quran or hadith
is if it's clear being for me it's
praying and if it's not i expect to be
checked why because prophet sallallahu
alaim said
and i'm a muslim pass on from me even if
it is one ayah and i'm a muslim aslan
so i'm proud of my dean and if i can
share something with regards to the deen
i will share it but if i make a mistake
with that and this is why i'm
very careful with the deen because i
have a lot of people say to me you need
to bring more hadith in you need to
bring more ayat and so on and i say to
the people
listen i am not an islamic authority
and if i say something that goes against
the dean
then the burden of proof is upon the
claimant
can you do a library on the last point
please on
you said the burden of proof is on the
claimant right so
if i yeah so if someone comes forth and
they say like
you know what you just said is on
islamic you're saying that the person
that's claiming is understanding
uh needs to provide evidence right you
get get closer to the mic bro
yeah a little too far all right yeah
thank you she wanted to clear that up
yes oh no gabriel you're good brother
okay okay that's that's a good point uh
brother mahdi i appreciate that that you
said that
and i've seen that through your videos
that you have claimed that
you are not a taliba elm as you said or
a [ __ ]
and i i respect that okay that's that's
great mashaallah
that's a good start however it's very
easy to claim something and say call
allah
rasool
[Music]
is like that's it right you say you
basically made an injunction within the
deen so you've said that in one of your
videos with brother hamza
uh you're reacting and sister milad
you're using
the word kate or cut like this is
there's no discussion about it
and it's easy to then retract and say
well i'm not an islamic scholar
because that kind of protects you so if
i make a mistake hey guys i'm not an
islamic scholar
but if i want to prove my point call
allah rasul this is
sunnah this is a sunnah this is not the
sunnah
prove to me that there's any i or hadid
that says or recommends
okay you've used the issues of mustahab
or macro in definition so
you're talking like an islamic scholar
but then when you are cross-referenced
or checked then you say well i'm not an
islamic scholar you know i
i can't be pushed in this i i expect to
be
challenged or or or
crossed or referenced or to be corrected
when i
i'm wrong so but that kind of puts you
in this safe position that no matter
what you do
you know you're kind of not accountable
for what you are saying
so i don't think this is correct my
brother my question to you is then
what position of mine do you take issue
with from a shadow standpoint
very good very good excellent
oh no
your discussion or what you are saying
are we are we being hurt can you start
again yeah you're good you're good i
start over all right all right
so it is your understanding and what you
have been
telling people of what is a
sunnah and what is not a sunnah with
regards to
previously married women or divorced
women
okay and this and the sharia uh you know
are called as a
ba okay or okay these are the two terms
of the quran and sunnah
okay this is muslim community should
stop saying this is a sunnah
that this is not a sunnah even though
in the video that you react to brother
hamza
a minute 28 you say it is a sunnah
but it's not the sunnah it is a sunnah
but it's not a
sunnah then you go to uh elaborate on
that
and then you are basically talking about
you know what is the af
and the aqua of the prophet alaihi
wasallam
meaning what are the sayings or the
doings of the prophet
how one takes presence over the other
his toll or his speech takes precedence
over his action and this is an issue
because it's not black and white like
that so you've taken that
which is a shady perspective even though
you're not at all
the point that men should
not marry women who are previously
divorced
because they have high body counts their
pair bond
is a problem you know and also
a lot of negative or negative words that
you've been using
about any man who would do that such as
i think one i know it's a it's a
i think a british term a cook or
something uh sorry i i really uh
i'm sorry if i'm pronouncing that let's
address
so the first thing i'm not telling men
not to i am asking if you come to me and
ask me for advice mahdi
there's a sister she's come to me she's
got five ex-husbands
and god knows what happened in hajjahlia
what do you think about this
i will say to him run for the hills i
thoroughly recommend you do not
marry her because a woman's hair bonding
ability
with a man is is compromised as she goes
from
one sexual partner to the next the
studies on this are clear
now your response has been in the past
but where's your proof from the quran
and sunnah
and my response to you is this if my
background
my my bachelor's degree is in sports and
exercise science
okay i graduated in 2013 in sports and
exercise science you
study a variety of different subjects
biomechanics
nutrition psychology sports psychology
anatomy and physiology so on
it's well established in sports that if
you perform a warm-up
of 10 to 15 minutes before the actual
competitive activity that you are much
less likely to get injured
than if you don't perform the warm-up
now if i come on to youtube
and i tell the people i have learned
such and such and the studies on this
are clear
that if you perform a 15-minute warm-up
before
your workout you're less likely to get
injured is there a burden of proof
upon me to find a ayah or a hadith from
the quran and sunnah to prove this
[Music]
there will be if you are claiming this
within an islamic context
i i like your example but it's not
applicable we're talking here about
uh divorced women all right from an
islamic perspective or psycholo
psychological perspective
what is the study that shows that women
who have been divorced and you have to
make a distinction bro when you look at
studies
divorced how many times once that's a
divorced woman that's a tiger by an
islam it is a woman
who is or i am okay
sorry uh so these are the two terms that
are used in the sharia
if she's divorced one
yes three times a hundred times is there
this
difference in the study between that are
your studies showing
that difference between that are the
studies that you're quoting applying to
muslim women in indonesia
or in malaysia or in india or pakistan
or is are these studies applied to
american women non-muslim
what what are you basically proving here
please try to be a bit more specific
when you are quoting these studies
so then the burden of proof can be on
the person who claims because if you
just say
the studies are clear which studies can
you please tell us
and the details of the study so in
psychology
you look at different variables and
okay so you have to control variables
why so that the
claim that you make in the end your
conclusion can be scientific
all right so i'm sure you've taken a
study yes i understand that you're a
smart guy
i can see that i can see that you read a
lot problem is
are these studies applying to the muslim
community here we're talking about
you're advising
young muslim men you're advising muslims
you're talking about nikah you're using
terms of sunnah
you're using terms of islam so my
question to you the burden of proof is
on you brother
are these studies to american women
apply to america and western women
okay so i can bring red pill
[Music]
are we there yeah i could bring you
these studies i don't have them to hand
on me right now i could bring them
and it still wouldn't add any benefit to
this discussion
but i have a question and that question
is this brother gabriel
i present to you two sisters one of them
has never been married before
one of them has been married a hundred
times which one do you prefer to marry
i'll marry the one that is has more
taqwa
that's a good answer so i'll prove i'll
provide a better context for that
discussion
i bring you two sisters and all other
things being equal
iman beauty so on
one of them has been married never been
married before and the other has been
married a hundred times
which are you more inclined towards
uh how many women do you know that i've
been married a hundred times rather
than i'll tell you why this is important
no no it's not for the sake of arguing
brother fayad you have to understand bro
if you're coming from a scientific
background and you want to use
a certain example make sure the example
is applicable my brother
if you tell me two women have taqwa and
beauty
and one has been married okay five times
or three times i can say yeah but i mean
me as a counselor for 17 years i haven't
encounter
a woman who's been married five i've
been counts an
average of eight people per day and 70
percent of those are women so at least
it's a
sample population that is way uh above
maybe what mahdi has experienced maybe
through his
interactions but as a as a professional
counselor
i have not met yet a female within the
um i was married
five times yet okay so when you use
when you use at least an example let it
be applicable when you're telling me 1
and 100 there's a shock effect there
brother it's like
1 100. i mean but but
but it's a good it's a good uh it's a
good point
i want to just if you don't allow me
just this number 100 okay
to see whether it has an impact on a
person's
uh taqwa in the sight of allah subhana
or in the sight of of who this person is
because in the end
when you marry someone the most
important thing that you look at as the
prophet saw salaam said marry a woman
for four
okay they didn't say about anything i
said for her religion is
the priority not the only thing talks
about that you can marry her for all
four reasons if you can get it
all right so sheikh saleh was asked in
the fatwa whether there's a difference
between a
married woman and
in the south subhanallah and he said
that he quoted the hadith and the ayah
sorry
it's about taqwa it's about her religion
she could have been married five times
which is a more
you know reasonable example to give but
maybe the guys that she was
basically with divorced her in the
muslim ummah
sir the the khaleej including the
northern african countries that brother
mahdi has his origins from
okay there are a lot of divorces that
are initiated for many reasons
not just from the women's side
throughout okay the past few years
wait are you cutting out
my point is that we need to look at it's
not just like oh one versus a hundred
all right even if you go to this example
does this take away
let's use the word body count that
brother mahdi has been using
the famous hadith of the prophet saws
because mahdi says
in his video to hamza he says
at i think he basically said it's not
my if allah forgives you
you know the person who has done
something wrong before a hundred men
okay she slept with the hundred men
it's like the person who has if they
make tawba it's like the person never
sinned
he says i agree with that man
i don't give you allah forgives you i
don't have to
subhan allah how can we say that when
the first hadith that you learn in
talabu
the first ejaza you get is
the people who have mercy the one the
most merciful will have mercy on them
have mercy on those who are on earth the
one who is in heaven who have
mercy on you so if brother he doesn't
want to forgive a woman
who's had five body counts let me use
his language or he's been married five
times
which is again in my experience
personally i have not met
yet one i don't know how many you've met
fayyad and i don't know
my brother
okay filling with about eight people
wait let me finish my point with about
eight people
per day uh i have not come yeah
so annie if this is the first hadith
that you learn
in it that you get in hijaz and when you
study and inshallah i recommend brother
mahdi
to do a bit of islamic studies inshallah
just as fayad and you know brother
ramirez is doing
but if this is the first and the
scholars say why because you have to
understand
mercy and how you deal with people okay
and that
everyone has a chance to repent and come
back to allah
speaking about a hundred the famous
hadith that we all know
the man who killed nine
and then he killed that hundred that
allah not enter him into jannah
okay so i mean to be honest whether
you're telling me like
one in a hundred other than the shock
effect you're still not making a point
bro you need to take each case
separately
the sharia looks at each case separately
each woman separately
each problem separately as a counselor
each woman
has a specific reason for marriage for
divorce
for problems a fatwa has his specifics
there is no mufti or no psychologist
even that just says hey this is 100 this
is one
which one would you choose no they look
at each case separate and that that he's
been putting everyone on the same plate
you know and i think if you were to
clarify things a bit more
if you were to say look guys when you do
the the vetting and if you find that she
has a huge
history and it keeps repeating over and
over again then yes person a person
would move with caution
but when you frame your arguments by
using
negative words swear words uh calling
women having high body counts like they
murdered someone
okay and then saying that allah forgive
you i don't have to forgive you
encouraging young men as you said to run
to the hill
man i think you're being unfair not only
to muslim women
but to islam in general and what you're
trying to preach
okay shall i go okay i just wanted to
say one thing that if
we could keep your answers you know
within two or three minutes
we can get somewhere because if one
person speaks like 10 minutes at a time
the other person goes like
20 seconds yes yes but remember the
of proof is on me right it seems that
it's been twisted on me so i'll make the
burden of proof bro i'll go all the way
out brother
uh and just to add to that if he said
does this
this personal experience add to the
discussion
yeah it doesn't so then why even bring
it up in his videos
if it doesn't add to this intellectual
discussion it does not add to his videos
it does not add to his verb
i i'm advised brother from the bottom of
my heart man
so just to answer that i i answered that
question already
i'll answer it again i only bring my
personal experiences into play
if i have first quoted a study or some
type of research first aside from that
anecdotal experience
is uh oftentimes worthless right okay
now the reason why i use an extreme
example with you is
many years ago i used to sit in the
class of sheikh
abu sahib al-bassam was the student of
that if you want to explain a concept a
concept that might be difficult
the often use extreme examples
to make the principle easy to understand
that is why i gave you an extreme
example but
for the purpose of entertaining your
your concern with that
i will reframe my question differently i
present to you two sisters
with all other variables being equal in
terms of their taqwa
in terms of their beauty to you and so
on and so forth
one of them has never been married
before and the other one has been
married five times
you will be her sixth husband which one
are you more inclined towards
i would sit with both of them i would
vet both of them and i would pick the
one that connects best to me in terms of
islam
taqwa in terms of understanding of life
it depends on the situation
if you have sit sit in the class with
sheikh al-bani student
you would understand that principles of
don't go just based on like
here's five here's one it goes based on
situations as i've been telling you
okay what's the point of you claiming
you're not a student of knowledge then
you're saying i've been sitting with the
uh with sheikh you know uh so and so
fulani
you know brother you need to pick what
you're trying to say here
because you're kind of jumping left and
right what i'm trying to say is brother
i would pick the woman that i would vet
and that's what i would recommend to all
the men they have to do their homework
i'm not saying yeah yeah just take the
one with five or just take the one with
one
it depends if you look at the hadith of
jabber
okay that you have quoted right about
the recommendation of mirroring a virgin
that the prophet sallam gave to jabber
when means he positions saying that i
have sisters and this hadith comes in
differently and he says i didn't want
this virgin woman to interfere between
me or cause a problem
between me and my sisters
so then i married a matron okay just to
use the
the uh the the english word so the
prophet salallahu sallam
said did he discourage him he said
this is better fazaka than this is
better so the prophet saws was presented
with the context
jabber made his argument right so the
process tell him at the beginning said
yeah why don't you marry
a virgin so you can play with her she
can play with you
and jabba explained his circumstance
so the prophet sam said for in this case
this is better for you
so now the ruling has changed it would
have been
brussels said hey we're virgin and then
the prophet saws tell him when he
understood context
he said this is better for you jabber
this is what i'm trying to say my
brother mehdi
when you are preaching to people and
you're calling people
it's not just a hundred or one you need
to look at each case
separately i'm telling you because you
said you're a muslim so if you're a
muslim it's not necessarily that you're
teaching people usually
is that you say you're a muslim you're
reaching out to muslim people
you are quoting quran hadith at least do
it properly at least do some studies and
understand
that you are responsible you cannot say
i'm not a student of knowledge ah when
the responsibility comes upon you
and people question
concepts are brought in and usual
principles are brought in kawaii are
brought in
then well i don't think the burden of
proof will lay upon me now it lays upon
you brother
so please understand context each each
ruling each difference so if it's one
woman
as jabber says this virgin could have
been a problem for me
and the prophet saws endorses that he
sees the issue she could have been a
problem what does he say he says she
could have come between me
and my sisters why because virgins need
extra time
virgins are a bit not so you know
basically accustomed to the challenges
of life because she's a virgin
okay not experienced yet with life so in
the case of jabber
allah this situation of him marrying a
matron
a previously married woman was better as
the prophet salallahu said
this is
so just to address your original point
just because i have sat in a class
doesn't or
i sat in the class of uh
doesn't mean i'm claiming to be a
student of knowledge but can you see
what's happening here brother gabriel
if i quote from the quran and sunnah i
am immediately questioned upon my
credentials to be able to cite and quote
that you have just done so
and when i don't quote quran and sunnah
the people come to me and say
why don't you quote quran and sunna so i
have been placed on the horns of a
dilemma and the way i
respond to that is very simple if there
is something i know of the deen
i'll share it and if there isn't i want
and if somebody has taken issue with a
statement i have made
and it's in conflict with the deen then
yes
the burden of proof is upon that person
now you mentioned
that the the hadith of jabba and i
absolutely and you keep mentioning that
you know you will look at the sister
and according to her situation and you
will judge and so on
i agree there are divorcee sisters who
are absolute
gems diamonds you have to dig for them
okay
wow right but we don't deal with
possibilities
we deal with probabilities and on a
bounce of probabilities
you are more likely to have success with
a sister who's not been married before
than a sister who has and i will end
this part of my
wh my speech with this hadith i will
just read it word for word
you know somebody sent it to me
narrated that the messenger of allah
said
marry virgin women for they have sweeter
mouths more fertile wounds
and are more content with what is little
and this hadith is what's the rating of
this hadith my brother i don't know
it is a hadith that is called hasan
according to imam al-bani
and the hadith that i accorded to is
sahih so yes it is important to also
understand
how we use proof my brother okay and how
we use context
that is why i've been using this issue
from a sharia perspective
okay this if you want to go to that
extent it's easy to just quote
and then say okay this is what i'm
trying to do so
well look some people are saying why
don't you quote more i'm not a student
of knowledge i keep
touching upon that point but then you
start quoting hadith
so decide yourself are you using hadith
and quran and sunnah to prove your
points
or are you not because if you're not
then stay away from it if you just want
to come from your personal perspective
okay but when you keep saying look i
will do it when i see it fit
i will do it when it you know it works
for me and then
anyone needs to correct me let them
correct me that's not a good stance to
take upon brother
either you the islam is not something
you play with that yeah i can quote
quran hadith but oh i'm not a scholar
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not attacking your
credentials did i say brother are you
qualified
have you uh do can you show me your
degree which scholars have you studied
with have we made the discussion about
that no no
the discussion is about your
understanding of divorced women and what
the sharia says about them
versus your understanding of divorce
women what red pill says about him so if
you're according to me
they're quoting it from a red pill
perspective all right man good job for
you
however whatever statistics studies
anyone brings in
needs to be pushed through a prism
through a filter
which is quran sunnah when we look at
the sharia in general
the sharia encourages to take care of
women does not make the distinction when
taking care of women
if about divorce or not actually there
are many ayat for example
surah nisa talks a lot about marrying
which women it talks about about divorce
women
and the rules around them about and so
on why because that's exactly what the
sahabas are doing they're marrying
and they were marrying them
all right that's basically when
pollution he comes in well guess how
many virgins are going to be left after
people start marrying
and there's divorce and divorce is quite
a lot does that mean now you're not
going to marry women anymore
no that's not correct so we need to look
at quran sunnah
that understanding not necessarily
statistics
or what you're trying to prove from uh
from statistics
we need to look at what does the sharia
say about a divorced woman
each case is specific i would if i would
be in your place i would be advising
brothers to say
be careful do your homework vet them
properly
make sure there's connection make sure
there's taco and this and that that's as
much as you can do my brother
but to just say well you know this study
shows that women who have been married
you know before or have body counts as
you call it you can't bear bond as well
as a virgin woman
and hence what do you think these men
are gonna think
even before they even go to marry
if they hear oh i've been married before
forget about five they're not gonna
think of numbers
they're gonna think of concept is she
divorced yes she's divorced
once yes so there's already a
preconceived
idea that divorce means bad okay brother
mahdi keeps talking about it
it's in the subconscious divorce is not
bad or anyone else is talking about it
right so what you're doing you're not
solving a problem brothers you said i
wake up every morning
i do it for free my brother just solve
it
you're not solving a problem you're
causing more problems men are not going
to marry
men are going to be
america care to take care of these women
who left alone and single now all these
divorced women
what do you think my brother is going to
happen in the society what do you think
these divorced women be the muslim or
not muslims
are doing do you know what they're doing
uh have you actually understood what
they are doing are you solving a problem
no you are not brother that's a that's a
good point that's a good point um but
before i get to that
look we've had a discussion now for over
an hour do you agree or disagree with my
position on divorces
i disagree with your position divorce is
100 excellent
from the quran and sunnah perspective it
does not it does not connect with
excellent
now your answer is proof evidence
testament to the fact that no matter
what i say
there will always be brothers willing to
run the risk of burning their hand
so that the rest of us don't have to
okay and there can always be brothers
who are going to succeed
marrying divorced women right can you
claim that that's not going to happen so
what are you trying to make which point
my point is very simple my point is this
if you're a mayor
we lost him no he's a no no go ahead go
ahead
right my point is simple brother brother
gabriel
on a bounce of probabilities not
possibilities as you keep alluding to
you see one of the funny things about
human nature is that
the less likely something is to happen
the more we gravitate towards it
actually happening
hence why so many people play the
lottery everyone knows that
it's next to impossible to win the
lottery and yet millions of people play
the lottery
so this is one of the peculiarities of
human nature that
the less likely something is to happen
the more we bank on
it happening now with the sister who has
had multiple sexual partners multiple
failed divorces the issue is not really
with the divorce per se because a woman
could get married
not consummate the marriage and get a
divorce that's a different discussion
right
the issue is with the imprint the sexual
intimacy
and on a bounce of probabilities
although there will be exceptions to the
rule
you are more likely to have pair bonding
issues with a woman
who has a sexual past than with a woman
who doesn't all right can i jump in here
real quick bismillah i didn't want to
cut in the middle of the conversation
but there are a few things i want to say
so first and foremost it is
very very beautiful and very important
that we use thought experiments and that
if we even
allude to extreme possibilities
to bring home a certain point but we
need to be careful
that we don't fall into a fallaciousness
to the mic
all right it's clear to me
okay yeah it's clear all right so
it's important that we don't fall into
fallacious ways of thinking when we have
these thoughts
thought experience for example the
thought experiment or the the um
example you just gave we go off of
probabilities okay 100
human human beings are wired to do that
if you go off these statistics
majority of of marriages end in divorce
majority
so by a probabilistic standpoint just
don't get married but that's so
opposed to islam you're allowed to but
that's not recommended
and then there's no muslims and then so
on and so forth this
is why red pill in the present day
as it stands is problematic because it
pushes a lot of it pushes for men just
not to get married remain as a bachelor
and play with different women that's
problematic and now with the example you
gave this program
just problematic that's haram exactly
one hundred percent one hundred percent
and this this is the issue when we delve
into all these issues
and the root of what we're saying is not
coming from a stem and i'll explain
so first let me let me talk about this
other uh proposition you gave before
this this thought experiment
you had two women who are equal in all
ways except one has been divorced a
hundred times
and one is a virgin or she's only been
divorced five times now
this this is gonna get a bit
philosophical right but think about it
like this
if they're equal in all ways it doesn't
matter who you marry
and if you're inclined to one over the
other then they're not equal
they're not equal and always the fact
that you're more attracted to one
because she was married less
proves that they're not equal in your
eyes in terms of beauty and in terms of
attractiveness
so to kind of derive a
objective truth from such thought
experiment
is something we should avoid because it
leads you down you know
basically the falsehood you're
absolutely wrong here ashirami and i'll
explain to you why
because i could have proposed those two
sisters to you without you having seen
them
and i simply say to you okay rami i have
a database of women
thousand women on my database i run a
marriage business marriage website
these are the list of sisters and then
we whittle it down to two
you've never met them you don't know
what they look like and you and i show
you their credentials their history and
so on
yeah and then i say to you rami which
one do you prefer to
explore a discussion with and then you
make your decision and your choice
yeah let me be more clear it's when i
said attractive i don't mean in terms of
the gaze
if you somewhat if let's say you've
never seen them right but the one who's
married less
is more attractive you're using yourself
as a measuring stick to determine that
so if you find someone married less is
more attractive than they're not equal
that's my point
i didn't use myself as the measurement i
asked brother gabriel what was his
preference yeah and
and and if if if none women who have
been married before
is a more attractive proposition to a
man which
don't then the whole line in general
would i would be allah don't want to say
it
you know they're pure untouched why is
that such a thing for a man
why are men so uh inclined towards the
untouched
so this is clear this is let's not try
and play with words
i mean you are right in saying that my
brother that the [ __ ]
are basically pure and untouched okay
you're talking about
janna okay we're also alcohol which
doesn't
give you uh sukhara or you're not
basically drunk would be permissible
yeah and talk many things will be
permissible in general we're talking
here about let's not take the discussion
to jannah
we're talking here about dunya and the
sharia is for the dunya things in the
sharia will not be applicable
desire here it's about you know
practicality
and about you know what problems you're
causing by the position
that you are holding many men will be
scared to marry
a woman where the talk about you know
her past or divorce comes in
which leads to a lot of divorced women
who might be good women
remain single you are saying that there
is a probability here that you are
alluding to
is this probability i want to reiterate
which i've already done a few minutes
ago
and i want to ask you haven't you said
the studies there is this probability
just from what you read
statistics does it apply to muslim women
does it apply to because as you know
when you do a study
it's psychology or whatever culture it
gets taken place it is one of the
variables that needs to be controlled
okay does this apply to muslim women who
are divorced or are you
talking about western women that is
important for you to ask because you've
been saying using the
the example of lottery and how people
gravitate towards things that will not
be achieved
you've also come uh you know you've also
compared women to stickers
you know what i mean i would be careful
again you know are we still alive
because we've lost them
uh we're still alive my brother yeah go
ahead we're still alive we'll still live
right so
so basically if you can we're live on
yeah it says love
okay all right yes sure yeah so
basically
do you remember anything from those
probabilities those stats whether it
applies to muslim women or not
okay i'll come to that so let me address
your first one because you make a few
points so i write them down
so you mentioned that it's not relevant
to the dunya because
uh that's dealing with the akhira with
jannah but i would
disagree with you it is relevant to the
dunya because that is what motivates us
in the dunya whilst we are here for the
akhirah
we have that innate desire to want that
even whilst we are here in the dunya
so it's completely relevant although
that happens in the archer that's the
first point
the second point is this you mentioned
does it apply to muslim women
well my question to you is what on earth
is the difference
aside from
what's the difference in terms of the
impact that it has on a woman
when she is intimate with a man and then
leaves him and then his internet with
him
intimate with another man and then
leaves him what's the difference
there's a huge difference my brother so
you should have experience
of dealing with women in this way as i
also have experience of dealing with
women not my personal anecdotal
but comparing notes with other men so
you should know my brother
that there is a difference that is
exactly what you
can tell me what i should am telling i
know from experience and also from
the way again i want to reiterate the
way the sharia looks at things yes there
is a difference between a
uh a woman who is a muslim and a
non-muslim from an akita perspective
from a sharia perspective in the side of
allah
perspective because everything the
foundation of a woman's ethics and
morals in the end
are tohit just because her name is aisha
fatima
and it says in her passport that she's a
muslim and maybe she prays
does not necessarily fulfill all her
requirements okay
there's a lot more that comes from tohit
in terms of ethics and morals
so yes there's a huge difference between
a woman who's a muslim and has been
divorced
and a woman who's a non-muslim and who's
been divorced because you're quoting the
statistics it is a variable that needs
to be
it stats they will look at num
at culture uh specifically when it comes
to women they have different cultures
i do agree with brother mahdi and that
feminism is
bleeding into the ummah it is hurting us
i am fighting it on my channel you are
trying to fight it many others are
trying to fight it
let's make sure we fight it correctly
because you will be pushing people
away from quran as
do you are you going to say things that
make people
deny allah and his messenger if we look
at the way of preaching
a preacher i'm not preacher for yourself
or a taliban or not
it doesn't matter you're responsible you
get on a platform you got followers
you say call allah call rasul and then
you say
i don't know whichever person you want
to quote you're responsible bro for what
you're claiming you are causing a
huge problem within our community if
you're gonna maintain the
uh arguments that
that basically will not forget about the
women what the women have the women
as we know very clearly uh from
you know some of the hadith of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi of denying the
you know the the goodness of the
husbands
all these things that are clearly stated
in the hadith we don't water it down bro
i've been quoting and talking about this
i've been getting heat forget about the
heat that you get from women
my problem with you is what you are
actually telling brothers
to do in your own words head for the
hill run to the hill
don't even consider these women my
argument is islam doesn't teach you like
that
okay the closest thing the most
important thing is taqwa
you take the woman you analyze her
lifestyle
she's not the kafira she's not you
cannot put in the same plate as an
american woman will all do with respect
there's even differences between the
muslim american women
and muslim british women muslim british
women
and muslim malaysian women or muslim
indonesian women
muslim uh saudi women or khalid women
there's the difference my brother so yes
as a counselor
i can tell you that there's a difference
if you want to take social psychology or
experimental psychology and their
principles
there is a difference you have to have
controls you have to have variables that
are controlled
there is a difference my brother for
sure okay
let's let's begin then bismillah do you
have any employees in your
employee do you employ anyone in europe
i do
right yes and when you employ them do
you look at their cv
what's your vetting process to ensure
that you employ someone who's suitable
my vetting process is basically my
interview with them so all the employees
that i have ibrahimovic
all these people i've known for more
than 10 years actually
ibrahim 20 years okay good so
oh that's that's what i've employed okay
often times what people want comfortable
with them
oftentimes what happens in the business
setting if you are to go to employ
to apply for a job is the first thing
the employer will ask you is for your cv
and they will ask you for references
typically two
of your previous employers why because
the best indicator of future behavior
is past behavior so if you have a sister
who's been through multiple failed
either divorces or sexual experiences
whichever of the two
and she has a track record for that the
best
indicator of her future behavior is what
already has come before
her
okay you're done can answer
okay brother all right you're again
applying um
a total different principle to marriage
and also you're applying a non-islamic
principle
to our discussion uh if you look at the
past of a person be it
them sleeping with different people in a
marriage not in zina
or even if it's in zina okay
in the end the person who makes taubah
the person who has come back to islam
who wants to do it correctly
is not something that you can blame them
from the prophet sallallahu alaihi
married
uh divorcees he has married uh
women who were uh you know uh
sorry uh women who've you know who who
are
their husbands passed away he's married
different variety
of women now i know your argument on
that we can get to that in a minute
but what i'm trying to say your past in
islam
it's not just like that like a cv you
cannot
a marriage just a cv are there elements
of that of looking at the past
uh experiences what if those um
the checks that you make you take two
references what if
okay uh they say hey man she's a good
woman she's been divorced by she was
married to the first guy who was a
druggie and yes again based on my
practice
many women end up with men who are
horrible
abusers drug addicts they don't pray
so she's been divorced the first time or
even herself she left the first marriage
okay she took hola for example because
the guy was doing
drugs the second marriage for example he
was basically a person who didn't pray
okay he didn't pray at all he started
not believing in allah so she took
divorce again
what are you gonna say about that is
that her fault that she was married to
two guys that she has a body count of
two
are you gonna dismiss that just
are we still there of what happened in
the past and this woman
and this woman yes we're still there and
this woman is trying
her best to do the right thing and get
married again is she written off brother
mahdi she has no more
right to get married or you need to
really look at it and understand this is
a good question
so you've mentioned a couple of
different situations scenarios a sister
who is married to a man who doesn't pray
a sister who is married to a druggie
right
on a bounce of probabilities not
possibilities
how likely is it that a sister is going
to be married to a druggie
very likely right now brother and this
time you initial you you know
many counselors will tell you that that
there are many men who do not pray wait
wait
uh let's let's if we go back to the
issue of prayer if you look right now
talk to the ulama
look at the muslim countries take sample
populations from the masajid
speak to people and see how many people
pray five times a day
okay then you will see that a lot of
women are married to brothers who are
not praying man
and a lot of women are married to i'm
sure
my question to you was are they the
majority
or the minority
who okay you mentioned the drug is that
the majority of men in this world who
are druggies or a minority of men
no they're not the majority most likely
they're a minority
so once again you're alluding to a
possibility
not a probability
okay and i've asked you for you to cite
those studies of the probability
and whether you're applying it correctly
you're talking here about also when you
are saying
uh this woman has five body counts this
woman has only she's a virgin you're
also talking about possibilities whether
this
marriage will fail or not or succeed or
not
okay you're talking about possibility
because the reality is you need to look
at each woman specifically
look at her taqwa look at her past look
at why she's been divorced
look at what are the circumstances
around this you cannot just preach to
people
just kind of you know openly in general
that hey be careful of women with high
body counts
be careful because that's why you call
him divorce now you haven't defined high
body counts you've used the term
100 i would agree that 100 is something
extreme
but you're basically brother when you
look at your videos you look at your
arguments
okay don't get caught up in details
you're basically telling people
do not marry divorced women be careful
run to the hill so the divorced woman is
sitting there and saying
but i'm not what mahdi is saying i'm not
like that
it wasn't my choice even to divorce by
the way the divorce is usually in the
hand of the woman of the man sorry
he's the one
so in general most of the divorces would
come from talaq even from my experience
as a counselor
most of the divorce you quoted a study
which i would like to see again whether
it applies to the muslim ummah
and muslim women who follow quran sunnah
and who believe in allah
80 of the voices are initiated by women
where
which setting what variables which women
does it apply to
i bring you the study would it change
your opinion
no but it will make my point it will
make my point that you have misquoted
you've used it the wrong way
you're applying these studies
do you see why i don't bother bringing
studies because as you just mentioned
if i bring it it still won't convince
you so it's it's useless but we can have
that discussion and i can bring you
those studies okay
i have a question for you i have a
question for you brother i'm coming
because
you've mentioned them a lot of points so
i have to go through them but as you
just mentioned
whether i bring it or not is
inconsequential to you you don't care
because you have your opinion which is
no it's not that's why
that's why that's why i don't
rest too heavily on bringing studies and
statistics to a debate
because people don't care right now you
mentioned a few things
if you agree that being that a woman who
has been married
in the extreme example to 100 men prior
is something that is
undesirable then every single number
that gets closer to that extreme is also
undesirable
right so 99 is better than 100 but 98 is
better than 99
and 97 is better than 98 on and on
until we come all the way back to the
sister who's never been married before
so each time she marries or has slept
with depending whether it was in halal
or not doesn't matter the point is the
sexual experience
each time she goes through another body
okay we get closer to that extreme
so now we have established that this is
undesirable
now one of the super chats that
was brought up just now brought up a
point that actually
i wanted to bring up so i forget his
name
and he mentioned actually i'll rephrase
it because
how i wanted to ask it was different
it seems to be okay for sisters to have
their standards when it comes to
choosing a brother
for example i don't want to marry a
broke brother
i don't want to marry a brother who's
less than five foot seven
i don't want to marry a brother who's
not ambitious
i don't want to marry a brother who's
not broke but he's average
he only earns 36 000 a year
which is the the u.s average i don't
want to marry a brother like that
and nobody bats an eyelid and yet when a
muslim man
comes forward and stands on his square
and says
to other muslim men you too must also
have standards
and it is undesirable for you to marry a
woman who has a sexual experience
why because it is more likely on a
bounce of probabilities
that the marriage will break down with
her than it is with someone who's never
been married before
please answer us that
it's a very good brother mahdi you keep
contradicting yourself you're saying i'm
not going to bring the statistics up
but you keep alluding to the statistics
you just done that five minutes
five seconds ago you can't answer the
question i i i i am answering the
question i am answer you cannot restrict
me to what i have to say
i am answering your question you keep
saying that i'm not going to bring the
statistic because it's not going to show
or it's not going to change your mind if
you can show me the point of bringing up
the statistics brother you're trying to
prove your point is just done 15 seconds
ago
you keep bringing up and saying the
issue of the statistic of the
probability versus possibility
you have repeated this in this debate at
least 10 times
is where i'm asked for the statistics is
to understand
the study itself whether it can be used
as a proof or not
if you can show me that this is
something that is applicable
to muslim women then we need to step
back and say man we have a problem
and now all these divorced muslim women
we have to put them in the same position
okay but you are using studies wait let
me let me finish let me finish let me
finish so you are you are using the
studying correctly
and then you say no i don't need to use
the study because it's not going to
change your opinion
but you keep going back to the study i'm
asking you give us the study
let us understand your study that you're
making your points on let us understand
that
uh you know who it applies to which
culture
muslim women non-muslim women and so on
and so forth okay
the issue of undesirability to go to
your question oh if it's 99
it's closer to 100. you're gonna move on
to another point and we have to address
the first one
okay so you mentioned uh the study and
so on and so forth
okay i don't have the study to hand i
can bring it for you but as i we have
just established it won't make the
blindest bit of difference to you
however you you have mentioned how can
it
does it affect muslim women i just told
you that well or is it just non-muslim
women
and i'm surprised that you think there
would be a difference but i will give
you a scenario a situation perhaps to
make this
this analogy clearer what if you have
a non-muslim woman who has a past she
has a
a big sexual past and it has affected
her
and then she embraces the deen she
reverts to the deen and she becomes a
muslim
are you now telling me all of that
baggage and damage
that has happened to her miraculously
disappears
as she becomes a muslim in the sight of
allah
it does in our sideshow
my question is not in this idea my
question is
in the sight of the the people
has her baggage and damage disappeared
or no
her past has not disappeared no doubt
what has happened however my brother
mahdi
you have to understand that i would look
at the person
and how islam has affected her i would
vet her it's
again you're talking about a possibility
here just in your words
you are
it's possibilities okay so that doesn't
really count what i'm trying to say yeah
there is a possibility
that it might not affect it there's a
possibility it will affect her i will
have to look at each case
specifically there might be a sister who
has her past
and her baggage carries on into her
islam i've worked with new muslims for
many many years and some of them do
carry their baggages into
the present and some don't and we look
at the sahaba
and the sahabi all of them had some
past men and when they embraced islam
did they look at each other and they
knew each other my brother used to
see each other making tawaf naked they
used to see
some of the women of mecca and i'm sure
brothers were the seed of the process
in they would make tawaf naked
in jahiliya they would stand at the door
with the door open which would allow a
man to come in have sex with her not
just a man
more than one man and then when finally
she gets pregnant she would call one and
she'll say you are the father
and the culture would accept it these
are the people who converted to islam my
brother
these are the people that allah
subhanahu ta says
okay these are the people who married
each other and they did not hold it
against each other you're talking about
a lot of possibilities brother mahdi
causing a problem because you are
discouraging men
from marrying paying attention uh
vetting
and making sure that the process of
vetting you mentioned standard for women
i agree with you man men should have
standards
should they discriminate and just write
a woman off if you are saying based on
divorce based on her divorce or how many
men she's been married to
uh or she had a past or this and that
actually you shouldn't even know the
past especially if someone has made
tawba
you shouldn't delve into that if someone
comes and tells hey bro look man
there's this and this and this you need
to look at that i don't disagree i don't
say no turn a blind
eye and don't you need to vet you need
to look
you need to look at taqwa understanding
of islam
you need to look at who she is today
because of islam
and just because she's been divorced
before you're gonna run to the hill
she's gonna be left alone she do you
think she's gonna behave you think she's
going to what does a woman
told us take care of women take care of
women there are so many injunctions in
the sharia
about women not just that towards closer
to they almost
the day of judgment towards the end of
times a man will be responsible for tens
of women responsibility
my brother if you're preaching
responsibility i'm sorry man but you are
not i would re
iterate to you my nasiha to my dear
brother mahdiatijani
is to reconsider your stance and your
positions
study some islam look at the correct
usage of the terms that you're using
if you don't want to represent islam
don't quote
then make sure you look at which uh
population do these studies uh uh apply
to
don't just generalize them to all the
muslim women just reevaluate your
position
fix a few things and then preach to
people to yes i understand bro you're
fighting feminism
i'm with you okay but if you're fighting
divorced women
and you are using this red pill type of
mentality to prove your point and then
you're painting it with quran and sunnah
i think you're doing a big disservice to
not only the muslim
women but the community are large
because this ummah is an
ummah if these women are alone they're
suff
responsible not only for the virgin that
you are marrying but for all the women
what if your mother or your sister or
your cousin is a divorced woman
and maybe she's gone through a bad
marriage you're not going to take care
of her there's responsibility
throughout the life of the prophet
sallam you want to look at uh
this is a hadith his sayings his words
oh which one takes precedence
it doesn't matter in this discussion is
that both are valid
the prophet sallallahu islam married
divorcees
who had body counts not just that maria
the cop his slave woman
julia other than that they're coming as
slave women bro they had body counts
okay they had body counts trust me okay
people might not be comfortable to
listen to this
did the prophet salallahu said well you
have a high body count i'm not going to
pair bond with you
he was a rajul which i encourage many
men inshallah to stand up and be
let's be rijal i'm not saying close your
eyes and say well
you know all these women we just married
them all no no no i'm saying this
each case is different use a better
judgment
and better principles better collide
better principles that are in line with
all right brother gabriel let's start
let when you've
got you're demoralizing a bit now let's
stop moralizing and just get back down
to the
intellectual not some bolts okay do you
see what the danger is with your message
gabriel do you see it i do not see that
injure my brother
i'm responsible for i say it's not
danger maybe to you but not to
to to the ummah i'll explain to you what
the danger of your message is actually
because
you are essentially almost
when a sister who is going through some
type of difficulty with her husband
here's this type of message that you
have just said that the brothers should
take
and you know help and so on and so on
and so forth and she is having
issues with her husband not major ones
because most women don't have major
issues
they have small issues that accumulate
over time into a mountain
right that's most of us she hears
someone like you say
brother should step up to the plate and
take one of these divorcees
what type of impact do you think that's
going to have on her
her endurance to want to continue
staying in her marriage
and keeping the family unit with her
children
and i emphasize the word children
because they are the ones who are hurt
the most
in divorce so what type of impact do you
think this has on that sister who is
considering leaving her husband
when she hears a message like you have
just delivered
of how it is upon us as muslim men to
marry these divorcees you know and not
worry about their past and so on and so
forth
okay thank you very much um have you
made this
point based on statistics or
probabilities or is this a personal
elective
no it's a question i'm asking you a
question what type of
impact do you think it will have on a
sister
who hears brothers saying brothers
married divorcees married divorcees
while she is unhappy in her marriage
okay do you see the problem with your
question how illogical it is because you
would ask me
to get into the mind of a woman and if
you know the answer to this question
you would be saying that you're getting
into the mind of a woman
unless you're going to prove with some
statistics or some probabilities or
whatever you're trying to make a point
here
it's irrelevant bro what kind of impact
will it have
do you have experiences with women to
know how they
think when they hear someone like me
speaking like that you made this point
against brother hams as well
because you said the same thing in your
video reacting to him
it makes no sense my brother because you
don't know what a woman thinks
can you say that all
dear brother and maybe the women can
comment on the
on this chat what is their reaction when
they hear someone like me saying
bro it's you know you should marry
taking care of you you should take care
of yourself
they will be very happy with this
statement and and and i'm whole i hope
they are happy my brother because
you have to understand bro the prophet
salallahu
has advised us to take care of women
and he did not make distinction okay
specific distinction i know that you
have made a distinction between
a divorcee and a widow we can get to
that debate if you want
but in the quran the sunnah
okay in general is
to take care of women there's a problem
in our muslim community
and the problem that we should be
addressing be it fayad myself
three muslims anyone else is how
feminism
is is bleeding into our ummah to stop
that
what you are doing is basically you are
attacking the wrong thing my brother
you're focusing
on the wrong thing and you're giving me
these philosophical questions
as if i were to get into females minds
and answer
this question i don't know what they
feel can you answer
okay okay let me twist that can you
answer what do they think what do they
think when they hear me talking like
this
respectfully brother gabriel you're
dodging a simple question
you know what the answer is but the
question doesn't serve your argument
very well
well if this is a simple question with
the simple my brother if a sister hears
that there's a encouragement in the
community brothers married divorces my
divorce is encouraging
yeah i'm not talking about the
permissibility of course
i'm not disputing that i'm talking about
openly encouraging
think what type of impact will that have
on a discontented system
now let's leave that because if we can't
agree upon that there's no point in
beating a dead horse
but do you know what the
the the the my main concern is
with regards to marriage are you
familiar why i am so
big on vetting and what to avoid and
what to look for and so on are you aware
of what is my main motive
um please enlighten me my brother my
main motive
is the nuclear home it's not a vendetta
against divorcees
i do not have a vendetta against them my
main motive
is if a man marries a woman he wants to
ensure
that he is going to marry a woman who
represents
the greatest pos probability
of making that marriage a success so
that when they have children
the children are raised in a nuclear
home
now i hope you wouldn't disagree with me
that children raised in single parent
homes
particularly single mother homes are at
a huge disadvantage and don't
i can hear that i can sense the chat
already i want to read the boy crisis by
dr will farrow who's done extensive
research on this
okay children raised in single parent
homes
are at a huge disadvantage to children
raised
nuclear homes so i agree so my vendetta
is not against women or a particular
segment of women
my war is against divorce period
because most divorces happen happen for
trivial reasons
the examples you have quoted of the
druggie
and you know the other examples you
cited they happen
and if that's the case i'm with you 100
but on a bounce of probabilities that's
most likely not the reason why a woman
pulled the plug on her marriage
now i say why the woman because for most
divorces are initiated by the sisters
now you're going to say to me where's
your statistics
in your previous podcast that you were
reacting to my
uh reacting to me with the other sisters
you mentioned that in the khalid
i don't know know which country that
hull has become like changing your shoes
it's become like changing your shoes so
my vendetta is not against divorcees or
a particular
demographic of women my vendetta is
against children being raised
in single parent homes i have them in my
inbox every single day
i have conversations with these men
every single day
and the damage as i'm sure you can
relate to is a counselor yourself who
has much more experience than me
and i'm not a counselor by the way but
you have much more experience and i'm
much more qualified than me i'm sure
you can uh you can you know that's what
i'm looking for
attest to this fact children being
raised in single-parent homes suffer
thank you brother i do attest to that
and you're right i will agree with you
on that
i will not agree with you on your
vendetta
it's a it's a very honorable thing that
you're trying to
stop people from getting divorced
because you want
and please do explain to us what the
nuclear family is
uh in a second but what your issue is my
brother
is that you are not given a solution for
reality islam deals with reality
okay you are dealing hypothetically and
you're basically
uh you know you're you're you're really
ahead of yourself because
the reality is that divorce is always
going to be there
you might as you said reduce a little
bit to some election
the basic bare fact that everyone can
see is that divorce
will be there meaning divorce women
will exist
to do with these divorced women how to
vet them
you don't you're actually going causing
a bigger problem
islam that's what i'm saying let's go
back to quran sunnah because
the objective my brother my brother
i have to correct you here you said i'm
not offering a solution i have offered
the solution
i have presented the solution earlier on
in this podcast i asked you do you
agree with my position on divorce after
having spoken for an hour
and you outright categorically said no
and then i said to you
excellent no matter how much people like
me speak about this discussion
there will always be other brothers
willing to roll the dice with those type
of sisters
that's fine you do you and that's okay
and you've had that intimate dialogue
with me now what do you think about
the general person who's in the chat
right now who disagrees with me
and hasn't had that intimate one-on-one
discussion
he is even more unlikely to agree with
me so don't worry brother gabriel
i remember my dear brother hold on i
remember sitting in the class of abu
sayyaf once as well and
one of the questions was shaykh if money
exchange office
is haram is haram to run a money
exchange office
then who will run the money exchange
when we go on holiday if everyone took
this opinion that it is haram
then who would do it and abu sahib's
answer was
simple and concise he said don't worry
there will always be someone willing to
burn their handful
so are you basically comparing what we
are discussing now
you're making a very false chaos or
false analogy my brother
we're talking here about divorce not
money exchange that's the problem with
you
you talk you compare my brother you
compare no no i'm not missing the point
you're talking about stats from
lotteries you're talking about women
being stickers
you're talking about money exchanges i'm
talking about divorce
islam offers a solution to what to do
with divorced women
okay it is a species it is a specific
solution you have to look at each case
and how to address this issue a lot of
divorced women in the community
is not something that is encouraged in
islam that's why pollution is allowed
that's why the prophet sallam and sahaba
not only the prophet sallam because you
can say
well what's for the prophet is not
necessarily for us the sahaba the tabe
they have married divorced women okay
because they understood
what it means to have a divorced woman
running freely around the muslim one in
the community just like that
be it she's 30 yes she's 35 yes she's 40
years she's 20.
it doesn't matter so islam my brother
not you
gives the solution in surah nisa in many
of the hadith
the akam on how to deal with divorced
women how to select a woman
the hadith of the prophet saw his
examples
all these things my brother it's not my
personal
experience i'm coming back again for how
i started this discussion
from a quran in sunnah perspective you
are coming in with quoting certain stats
and so on but when we call you to bring
us and to tell us is this applying to
muslim women specifically
you say well i can bring the stat i can
quote you this book all right no problem
we can wait for that what i'm trying to
say is bro you're causing a problem
you need to fix that islam fixes that
not me islam fixes that not jibril not
my counseling
islam the prophet salallahu fixes that
islam
addresses has so many okay
in so many different you know
books these issues are discussed
as to how to deal with divorces how to
select a woman
what is this what it never this do they
mention just body counts
stickers uh you know exchange you know
money exchanges
they stick to real problems and real
issues
and just to mention again bro that's the
thing you try to get in the head of
people
you're asking me what do you think a
woman thinks when she hears
what your brother are saying you're you
know you're glorifying
marrying divorced women i'm telling you
that this is
islam tells us to fix this problem
to make sure that women don't stay alone
there's a responsibility on men
what i would suppose women would think
when they hear
this they have hope they have hope not
to leave their marriages bro
that's between them allah they have hope
that if they are divorced
we're not talking about the woman who is
not divorced and she's toying with the
idea
okay no i'm talking about here divorced
women
and what a muslim man how he should vet
her
how he looks at a divorced woman okay
and i think my speech
and the way i approach it based on quran
sunnah is to instill
hope okay give god tidings
don't push people off this is uh
rasulullah
when he enters medina okay you want to
make sure
people have hope that yes
there is hope allah is merciful that
allah will forgive that allah should
help us
that we should change ourselves i think
that we need to instill hope i'm not
seeing being unrealistic
because i'm telling you what quran
sunnah is saying i'm also telling you
what the prophet saws
if you're saying that this is only
restricted to the prophet the sahaba did
the same thing
because they learned from him and the
salah did the same thing and the tabain
and the muslim ummah has been dealing
with and
working at it be it successful or not
the outcomes in the end
is part of your qatar is part of many
things
what i'm trying is the solution my
brother there are a lot of divorced
women
when you talk the way you talk my
brother is discouraging men
from even trying forget about mary for
even going
considering the possibility looking at
their taqwa
important other than the body count
so far you're basically focusing on body
count
which i believe is uh very very skilled
my brother what's the next discussion
point
pause pause pause pause on i know that i
had to
dip out to the bathroom um my dad for
that
uh there's a lot to unpack i'm loving it
so far guys
i gotta hit prayer so if i don't make it
back in time i won't let all y'all know
i love you all for the sake of allah and
um
again if i don't make it back um
okay let's not bore the audience let's
move on to the next point what's the
next discussion point you would like to
talk about brother gabriel
that's it my brother that's it i just uh
advise you
with uh you know my sincere advice i got
nothing against my brother
you know i think you are a very dynamic
person you are
an you know your smart guy you read a
lot you know
just reevaluate your positions i'm not
saying all your points are wrong
i do feel that a lot of it comes from
your personal experience as you have
mentioned in a lot of your videos
okay even though you say it's irrelevant
to the discussion but you do bring it up
in your videos
i'm just saying is reevaluate your
position uh
study a bit more and i would say make
your
filter for how you see the world
quran in the sunnah not red pill not any
other
philosophy or understanding of life make
it islam
okay and i think you could preach to
people uh to build as opposed to
you know uh you know destroy uh
and i'm not saying that you are a word
you've used that's a very potent word
you have used build
instead of destroy and i like that word
you know why i like that word because if
a man is going to get married to a woman
he's going to build a family if he's
going to get married to a second wife
he's going to
build another family and we want to
maximize i agree
we want to maximize our probabilities of
building families
with women that are most likely to
provide amanda
may allah bless you brother honestly uh
uh i i i don't want to
praise myself or anything like that but
when the three muslims approached me
when i watched your podcast
fayat can verify i said i saw not many
problems with it right i don't see the
big heat and so on
because i saw you as an intellectual a
lot of the points you're making were
valid and i think you do have a lot of
great points
then it was just these two issues that i
had you know some issue with
is my advice my brother you can do
whatever you want okay
uh we muslim should be inshallah united
towards
bringing islam as you said building a
family maximizing
i know that we have a lot of common
enemies subhanallah
and you know this discussion was only to
try to clarify some things
and i think people gave you a rod raw
deal and even so
you know whatever it happened in your
past bro everyone's got a past
okay i wouldn't put it out there for
people because people are very
judgmental
they will write you off i know you don't
care about people and i i respect that
bro i like that about you
they could care less about what people
say but
you know i would say that just care
about what you say and how
it could help help people
it could help people to maybe
build this uh you know this this ideal
that you have or this uh
very honorable you know endeavor to
build a nuclear home
to build families to reduce divorce i'm
with you bro may allah put barak in that
for you
waiting for you bro i know romney got
thoughts
uh subhan allah i mean every time
there's a discussion like this
my mind usually when i'm in that kind of
mode and like really reflecting there's
a million things i want to say
i cannot cut off the brothers while
they're speaking this is
you know to be frank mainly between the
two of them uh so alhamdulillah
allah you know allow good to come out of
it
um anything i have to say i feel like
that the two things i actually wrote
down
are kind of reiterations of what gabriel
was saying so
uh i'll say them you know for the sake
of inshallah but basically
it's that everything in life every
single thing is an islamic matter
there's not a single thing on the face
of earth that you can bring that's not
an aesthetic matter
everything is and this is how we have to
live our life this is how we have to
take the deen and even in the example of
fired fit may allah bless him
and his his fitness and his um
adventures in sha allah i mean
but even the example of firefight
everything he does has to be sure
compliant everything he does has to be
within islam and if it were to come to a
point
one day where it has become an ideology
or called and it's on islamic then you
have to denounce it
you are obligated to denounce it for the
sake of islam because the only thing
allah accepts is islam
at the end of the day he will have to
denounce that which is
conflicting with the religion but just
okay look at islam islam has many sex
right just because something has been
innovated in islam do i now denounce the
whole religion
no i denounce what is the bidder what is
wrong and i keep stick to the rest so in
this example
if something happened to fayad's fifth
uh you know organization he has to
denounce that bit
and keep the rest i agree yo gabriel
what is the e consequence of somebody
saying something like this
of what sorry say again in the the child
whoever says
not muslim on this uh
said one of them will become that okay
subhanallah be careful man brothers and
sisters you know that's the problem with
these spectators you know
who have uh you know sadly just come
here as entertainment we're not here as
entertainment my brothers you think this
chat has been put as an
entertainment or this thing please fear
allah
and retract that apologize because this
is totally totally
totally unacceptable okay so
yeah 100 basically saying that if you do
take fear on someone and they are a
muslim then you
yourself are a catholic so i understand
this is something that's been done
honestly on a large scale unfortunately
something you have to avoid challenge
um to make my point more clear i said
when it becomes
an ideology you have to denounce it
when it becomes an ideology at that
point you have to denounce it because
now you're taking the dean of the
netherlands that's my point
whether it has or hasn't i don't want to
argue about like you know specifics
every case has its specific kokum and uh
lastly what i want to say is
islam needs to be done by the scholars
right i'm i'm i wouldn't even call it
like i am assuming
i'm learning but i'm not a qualified
person anyway everything that i say
i have learned from my teachers who are
qualified
so when we bring a hadith when we find a
hadith and
we derive a ruling or a statement or
advice or something
from the hadith we have to be very
careful
because it's very possible and i would
even say
likely that the conclusion you come to
is unsound because you don't understand
the usual behind the fair
you don't understand and this is why
we have scholars because they do study
it they spend their life studying it
and no one can master everything so we
go to specifics of that field now me as
a layman i can't take one hadith
out of all the quran and all the hadith
and then come to a conclusion based off
of that
without any credentials or anything like
that so that's just my final point
that as muslims we are literally
obligated to give this respect to the
dean
everybody like me you and everybody here
absolutely
hundred percent 100 100
all right i don't think this will be the
last conversation but i do think tonight
it's coming to an end it's getting hella
late bro i think it's like
one or two a.m for uh mahdi
this is very fruitful and brother
gabriel
very nice you know it is important
that we present different ideas
and then sharpen them on a public public
platform
if you think of a knife when you want to
sharpen a knife you take the sharpener i
don't know what you call it the thing
that sharpens the knife
and you apply pressure from the right
from the left
that's how the knife becomes sharp if
you only apply
pressure from the right eventually it
will just fall over
but when you apply pressure from the
left we can sharpen our argument our
understanding and hopefully
get a clearer picture of you know what's
correct and what's not
so jazakallahu for this opportunity i
appreciate it
for your time
bless you i mean
all right guys if you guys made it this
far smash that like button we will have
more discourses like this
this is not the end um and yeah guys no
hate
no no shade no pettiness no okay mahdi
won gabriel one none of this
like guys if you want truth
we're here to do our best that's it and
may allah
you know decide that on the on the final
hour i mean
i mean
[Music]
foreign